let's go to Jack from Atlanta Jack from
Atlanta welcome to the program what can
I do for you today
hey David can you hear me yeah
awesome well thank you so much I have a
question I know you've repeatedly said
that you still do not believe that Trump
will ever see one day in prison I'm
still wondering given all the evidence
and the severity of this arraignment he
had yesterday and the charters being
white against them why do you still
believe that so I've actually updated my
view on this Jack and I'm glad to have
the opportunity to do it again prior to
this week prior to this recent
indictment I believe that there was no
chance Trump would even see a day inside
of any kind of cell I now believe that
it is unlikely but possible so I have
sort of upgraded or downgraded depending
on your perspective my uh my view on
that on the basis of this latest
indictment
well one could only hope and uh one last
quick question I I thought of it after
the last speaker uh gave his question do
you find it at all startling that a lot
of Corporations have actually foregone
posting their logo as a rainbow logo for
pride month because it used to be the
case where almost everyone would do that
but now I guess maybe they've realized
that hey now it's not financially viable
to do that anymore does that at all
scare you you know I don't know that to
be true and what I mean is I'm not
saying you're lying I just pay so little
attention to what corporations are doing
as far as the the logos I know that on
the very powerful David Pacman show
Discord we did do a modified server logo
that includes the rainbow stripe for the
month as we always do I I it's I'm not
are you aware like what specific
companies used to do it but aren't doing
it anymore
well I know I've seen like a lot of just
random companies like Cisco or Starbucks
will post their Twitter a profile
picture as their logo but the
rainbowified version and I feel like I
just have seen very few of those this
year and I mean I given I just saw this
isn't exactly the logo thing but I saw
on the news today that Starbucks is
actually rolling back some of its Pride
decorations at over half of its stores
so I was just I don't know it's just a
little bit startling how now a lot of
Corporations I mean yeah rainbow
capitalism is a lot of times empty
virtue signaling but it's just I don't
know it's a little bit worrying that now
that's being it's it's being perceived
as hey this isn't the right thing to do
given the current political climate yeah
I mean because I don't have the actual
empirical information in front of me let
me comment in this way
we all know that the vast majority of
these decisions are simply marketing and
PR decisions to increase the bottom line
it wouldn't be shocking to me that if it
became disadvantageous to do the pride
thing that companies would immediately
stop doing it I would find it
disappointing and sad because that would
be a horrible thing that it's it's no
longer that it would be unprofitable in
some way to uh just say hey like we're
we're on board with with just treating
everybody the right way uh it wouldn't
be a huge shock because these are at the
end of the day they've always been
financially oriented decisions
exactly well thanks for taking my call
David have a good one my pleasure there
goes Jack from Atlanta very powerful
declarations there and we are glad to uh
glad to hear them why don't we go to
Mali from Utah Molly from Utah welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hi
um so last time I got cut off I don't
know what happened but uh there the
thing I was going to talk about is that
the DSA has over 185 seats both state
local including National okay Molly just
just just with total peace and love
if we can get I know that there was a
very long lead up going on and DSA is
not something that I'm super engaged
with and know very little about it so so
I just if we can get to the question
part relatively sooner even first I can
tell you whether I can even weigh in I
don't want to waste your time you know
yeah
um but it's basically that they've been
doing local actions they've been doing
local activities and have been gaining
ground so uh what do you think about
those efforts when it comes down to uh
electoral reform I know nothing about
what the DSA is doing or where they've
been gaining ground and as a
non-socialist myself it's not something
I'm advocating for
it's uh over the entire country they've
been getting on since 2016. and you you
mean in elected office yeah elected
offices both state and local and
National that there's like five members
of Congress that are DSA members listen
what I can tell you is when movements
succeed at getting candidates elected
it's good for them but beyond that it's
really tough for me to say say too much
more it's not a group I'm a member of or
one I'm you know supporting at this time
sure I just I would recommend looking
they seem to be advancing pretty well
and that's just like the the Opium of
like change is possible they are able to
do it all right Molly from Utah thank
you very much for the call I appreciate
that let's take a very quick break we're
gonna go right back to Discord and hear
from more people so don't go anywhere
we're just taking a very short break